okay so today we're going to do some
more live coding and we're going to talk
about something which is quite close to
my heart because I wrote some of the
early papers on it many years ago and
that's something called functional
parsing or combinator parsing before we
get started with actual live coding I
want to begin with the question and the
question is what actually is a parser so
for me a parser is a program which takes
a string of characters as its input and
as its output it produces some form of
tree and the idea is that the tree makes
explicit the structure in the input
string so that's a bit of a mouthful so
let's have a simple example to explain
what's going on with this so what we've
got here is we've got a string of five
characters two plus three times four and
that's our input string but when we look
at this we know that that's not just a
random sequence of five characters it's
actually got some structure to it so in
particular we've got three numbers here
two three and four I'm about to
arithmetic operators we've got the plus
and the times and one of the things we
learn at school is that the x happens
before the plus so you really do three
times four here and then you add the two
on at the end so that's our input string
so what a parser does is it takes a
string of characters like that and it
tries to recognize the structure in the
form of a tree and the tree we would get
from a parser is something like this
here and you see we've got some leaves
in the tree the leaves are the numbers
two three and four and the nodes in the
tree are the two arithmetic operators
that's the plus symbol and the time
symbol and you can see the structure of
the tree reflects the fact that we do
the multiplication first we multiply
three by four and then we do the
addition second so that's the basic idea
of what a parser is it takes as input a
string of characters and as output it
produces a tree so it's really a
function is taking an input as a string
and an output as a tree so we've seen
what a parser is it's a function that
takes a string as an input and produces
a tree as an output so now we want to
think how can we actually implement this
how can we implement the idea of a
parser and I'm gonna do this in Haskell
today but it doesn't matter if you don't
know anything about how scale because
I'll be explaining everything as I go
along and actually nothing I'm going to
show you today is specific to a language
like ask
you can do in any general-purpose
programming language so if you do a web
search for a Combinator parsing or
functional parsing and then whichever
language you're interested in you'll
find the same kind of stuff which I'm
going to show you today so it's not
specific to the house gal setting so
what we're going to do then first is
we're going to define precisely in our
programming language what it means to be
a parser we're going to define a new
type called parser and it's simply going
to be a function which takes a string as
an input and produces a tree as an
output so it captures the very simple
idea of what we are wanting to do a
parser is a function that takes a string
as an input and gives the tree as an
output and the arrow here just means
that we have a function from one thing
into the other so this captures the
basic idea of what a parser is but
unfortunately it's not sufficient to
program with we need to refine this a
little bit to actually write programs
with this so the first little refinement
we're going to make is that a parser
might not consume all of its input so
for example if we're trying to parse a
number like two we maybe we find the two
and then maybe we've got some more stuff
left in the input string that we need to
parse and if we want to chain parsers
together we're going to need to have
access to the remaining interest rate
that we didn't manage to consume so the
first little refinement that we'll make
is rather than just returning a single
tree we're actually going to return a
pair now we're going to return two
things we're going to return a tree as
before and we're also going to return
the unconsumed part of the input string
so that's the first refinement we've
made the second refinement we're going
to make is that a parser may not always
succeed we may be trying to parse a
number and we don't find the number we
find something else so we need to have a
way of representing that our parser can
fail so the way we're gonna do that is
we're actually going to make a parser
return a list of results rather than a
single result so lists and Haskell are
denoted using square brackets so this
simply means that rather than returning
one pair of results we could return a 0
or 1 or 2 or as many as we like and the
idea is going to be if our parser can't
pause so it doesn't succeed we'll return
an empty list of results and if it does
succeed we'll return a list
with one pair in it will turn a tree
that represents the structure of the
input string and we'll return the
unconsumed part of the input
but because we're working with lists
here we could actually be more flexible
we could return to three or four or five
or as many as we like parses and this is
actually quite a good flexibility
because for some languages the input
string may be ambiguous maybe we're
trying to parse English and English
sentences don't always have one parse
that can be interpreted in many ways so
this type here is giving us a
flexibility to return many results if we
wanted well not actually going to use
that flexibility today but it's nice to
actually have it so I haven't told you
what the tree data type is here and
that's because I'm actually going to get
rid of that now sometimes you may want
to return a number or a program or some
kind of other structure so we're going
to replace that specific type of trees
by some arbitrary type a and I'll make
this a parameter of my type this is our
final type which we're going to work
with today what we're saying is that a
parser whose results have type a is
simply a function which takes a string
as an input and then it gives a list of
results and each result is a pair
comprising a single value of type a may
be a tree may be a number may be
something else and then an unconsumed
part of the input string okay so this is
our final type and if you look in any of
the articles or books about these kind
of parser combinators or functional
parsers you'll find the type very
similar to this there it's quite a
mouthful again so let's think about how
we could understand this in a simpler
way and actually we can write a little
rhyme to understand what's going on with
this type so let me write the rhyme out
for you as a comment so what we can say
is a parser for things is a function
from strings to lists of pairs of things
and strings this is a little dr. Zeus
trying to tell you what a parser is or
what a functional parser is and that's
actually how we remember this type so
that's our basic type now we've seen so
far apart there's basically a function
from strings to trees but in order to
actually program with these kind of
things we need to refine the type a
little bit and this is the type we'll be
working with today but you don't need to
worry about the details of it just
basically think it's a function from
strings into trees or some other kind of
structure what we're going to do now is
we're going to
the parsing library so I'll start out
the compiler this is a library which
contains a whole bunch of parsing stuff
which allows us to program with parsers
of this form this is a parsing library I
wrote myself I'll see if I can get Sean
to upload it as part of the video a
parsing library comes with any
programming language you can think of it
again if you just search for paas
accommodators functional parsing
whichever language you like you'll find
the library which gives you all sorts of
basic ways of building parsers and
that's what I'm going to show you now
all of these libraries work in the same
way so you have some basic primitives or
basic building blocks for parsers and
then you have a way of combining parsers
to build bigger parsers so it's like a
kind of Lego okay or a construction kit
you have some basic breaks the you can
do things with and then you can put
those bricks or components or primitives
together in all sorts of different ways
so I'm going to show you a few of the
primitives and a few of the combining
forms and then we'll do an example the
first primitive one to show you it's
very simple it's just a way of parsing a
single-digit so what the digit parser
does is it takes a string of characters
and it tries to consume a single numeric
digit off the start of that string okay
and you might think well what is pars do
here what parse does is it takes a
parser which in this case is just digit
and it takes an input string to that
parser and it just applies one to the
other so of course this parser here is
going to succeed because we do have a
digit at the start of the input string
so we get exactly the expected result we
get a list with one pair and the first
thing in the pair is the actual digit we
get the character 1 and the second thing
in the pair is the unconsumed part of
the input and that's something we could
then try and parse subsequently with
another parser we can test does this
thing fail properly so if I give it an
input string that doesn't have a single
digit at the start then it's going to
fail so if I give it the input string
ABC there's no digit at the beginning so
we're just going to get the empty list
of results so I'll show you one more
quick primitive if i parse a single
character say an a from that string and
that will do the right thing if I pars
single character a and I didn't have any
at the beginning then it will fail okay
so we've seen two basic parsing
primitives here we've seen a way of
parsing a digit
a way of parsing a specific character
and we seen that these things can
succeed or fail and in the library or in
any of these libraries there'll be a
bunch of these basic building blocks or
basic bricks or primitives that you can
use to build up your parsers where
things get more interesting is when you
think how do you combine these kind of
things how do you use these basic bricks
to build actually useful parsers let me
show you an example of this so there's a
parsing combining form called sum and
what it does is it takes a parser as its
input and it tries to apply it one or
more times as many times as possible so
if we're trying to parse some digits
what we're trying to do is consume one
digit then two then three and as many as
we can until we don't find any more
digits okay so if we apply the sum digit
parser to the string one two three then
it will do the expected thing that will
consume all three of the digits and then
we'll get the empty string left here so
that somehow gives us a form of
repetition and we also have a very
simple way of making a choice as well so
if I do I want to make a choice here
between a digit and a letter and let me
parse the string ABC one two three so
what we've got here is this funny symbol
here with the three symbols that's a
choice operator it says do that or do
that so if I try to par as a digit or a
letter what it's going to try first is
it will take the first character in the
input string and say is it a digit if so
I'll pause it and if it's not a digit
then I'll go over to the other side and
say is it a letter and I will try and
parse that you can see what's happening
with this particular example here if I
look at the first character is not a
digit it's a letter so when I apply the
digit parser it would fail and then the
or operator or the choice operator here
will go over to the other side and say
well is it a letter instead and of
course it is so we can parse the single
a off the frontier and then we get
everything else as unconsumed
and of course if we wanted to be a bit
more clever we could combine some of
these things so I could say some digit
or letter get my brackets write ABC one
two three and then that will parse
everything because all I'm doing here is
I'm repeating or iterating the choice
between either parsing a single digit or
a single letter and I've got a string of
digits and letters
so I can parse the whole thing so I've
consumed them all and then I get nothing
left at the end so what we've seen so
far is some basic building blocks and
we've seen a couple of combining
forearms we've seen a way of doing
repetition which is some and we've seen
a way of making a choice which is the
funny operator in the middle there what
I haven't shown you so far is how to do
some form of sequencing and this is the
most common thing you typically want to
do with parsers you want to say do this
and then do that and maybe do that as
well you want to sequence things
together so I'll actually show you a bit
of the parsing library here so here's
the parsing library and I don't want to
go through all the details of this but
one thing I want to know is it's quite
short if I kind of scroll down here I
think it's about four and a half screen
folds and I've got quite a big font here
and this is actually already quite a
sophisticated parsing library so shows
you the power of this method that you
don't need hundreds of lines of code to
write parsers for and a half screen
fills is a library which is fully
fledged
and you can basically implement any
parts that you like using this so I'll
show you a couple of examples of
sequencing the first example I want to
show you is a parser for natural numbers
so what's a natural number it's just a
non-negative integer like 0 1 2 3 or 10
or something like that so you think how
do you parse a natural number well I'm
going to use the sequencing notation for
parsers which is to do notation and the
dude notation is very simple you write
the word du and then you have a whole
bunch of parsers one after the other and
it just runs them each in sequence so
the first thing here is we're going to
parse some digits because that's the
basics of what a natural number is it's
just some digits and if that succeeds
I'm going to call all those digits X's
so XS is just going to be a list of all
the digits and then what I'm going to do
here to be a bit more flexible probably
when a par is a number I don't want a
string of characters back I actually
want the number so I'm going to pass the
string in to a little function called
read which just converts the string into
a number and then I'm going to simply
return it so the basic idea here is
we're sequencing two things together
we're reading some digits or pausing
some digits and then we're translating
those into a normal number and then
we're returning it and we're sequencing
those things together using the do
notation here so just one more little
example because we'll use this in a
minute here's how you could parse an
integer so an integer is either a
negative
number or a positive number so there's a
choice there so we're going to use the
choice operator so here's the or
operator which we've seen a few minutes
ago and the two parts here just say have
we got a negative number or have we got
a positive number so deposit for a
negative number we use the du notation
because we need to do three things so
the three things are here so if we're
trying to parse a negative number the
first thing we do is we parse a minus
sign so we're using the char primitive
that we saw previously that will parse a
minus sign then we're going to parse a
number and call it n and then we need to
remember that we need to make it
negative so we negate it and then we
return it so again here we're just using
the simple idea of sequencing three
parsers one after the other and then the
orosi here says or we can just have a
simple natural number okay so this
illustrates the idea of sequencing and
if you've seen some of my previous
videos you may recognize the du notation
here and this is because parsers form an
example of what's known as a monad and
in fact for me parsers being monadic is
one of the key ways to understand what
and where that is so if you've seen them
on on video or even if you haven't seen
it maybe you have a look back at that
and if you find it interesting maybe
look up some of the work which people
have done on monadic parsing and it's a
really good way to get a very good feel
for what's going on with both these kind
of parsers and monads as well we've seen
that parsers are basically functions
they take a string as an input and they
produce essentially a tree as an output
we've seen some basic primitives for
consuming single digits and single
characters and things like that and
we've seen some basic combining forms we
can have repetition with some we can
have choice and we can have sequencing
so we've got our basic kind of building
blocks for making larger parsers so
let's wrap this up now by doing a little
example an example I want to do is to
build a really simple parser for the
kind of expressions or arithmetic
expressions that we saw back at the
start so things like two plus three
times four so what I'm doing here is I'm
writing a Haskell program which is going
to implement this parser what I've got
in the first line here is simply
importing the parsing library which
we've just seen it's just four and a
half pages of code it's very
straightforward and what we've got here
in the comments is a simple way of
writing down what the
tax or form or structure of expressions
are and this is what's known as a
grammar but it doesn't matter if you
don't know what a grammar is because the
basic idea is very simple here the first
line says an expression can be one of
two things so this means or here in
grammars so an expression can either be
a term plus an expression or it can be a
term and then in turn a term could
either be a factor times a term or a
factor and finally a factor can be a
bracketed expression or an integer so
there's three simple rules here which
explain the form or structure of what a
simple arithmetic expression can be it's
actually quite a lot of things going on
here but the only key thing I want to
point out is we've got three rules
because there's three different levels
of priority in an expression so the
highest level of priority is brackets so
that's one thing you learn in school you
learn that you do the brackets first
that's the highest priority thing the
middle level of priority here is
multiplication so that's thing in the
middle rule and the lowest level of
priority is you do addition and that's
sitting at the top row and again this
priority order is something you learn at
school you do brackets first then you do
multiplication second and then you do
things like addition last and these
three rules are just making that precise
and again if you want to know more about
grammars you can you can search on that
and you'll find a lot lots of
information about the part online so
what we want to do now is take this
little grammar and implement it as an
actual parser and this is very
straightforward to do because we're
using this functional parsing idea
essentially we just take those three
grammatical rules and we just implement
them using the combining forms and the
primitives that we've seen so it's a
very straightforward translation so the
first one is we want to say an
expression can either be a term plus an
expression or a term so let's do the
first part of that so we've got term
plus expression so what we're going to
do is parse a term and if that succeeds
call it X then we're going to parse a
plus character then we're going to parse
a expression and call it Y and then
we're going to return X plus y so
there's four things going on in sequence
here we're first of all pausing a term
then we're pausing the plus character
then we're pausing an expression and
we're getting the values here x + y
we'll be numbers and then we're going to
simply add those two numbers together so
you can see here we're actually doing
more than just parsing we're actually
evaluating the expression as well and
that's one of the advantages of this
approach to parsing that it's not just
about building a tree you can actually
process things as you're going along and
we're actually processing them here by
doing complete evaluation so x and y
will be numbers which result from this
term in this expression and then we just
add them together here and return the
result then the last part of parsing an
expression is we can either be a term
plus an expression or we could be a term
so we just use the choice operator and
we get of 10 and these five lines here
are our full parser for expressions so
we had this one rule up here an
expression could be a term plus of
expression or a term and we just
translate it directly into our parsing
notation and again the key observation
here is that the grammatical rule here
looks basically the same as the parser
so let's look at the second rule and in
fact it's pretty much the same as the
first row except a few symbols are
changed so let me just copy it and I can
just change it so I can say a term can
be a factor times a term and then I can
do a multiply there or I get a factor
okay so in just a few key presses I've
managed to implement my parser for terms
and again the point to note here is that
the grammatical rule here looks
basically exactly the same as the parser
okay I've just got a few more symbols in
here because I'm actually writing a
program to do parsing or actually
evaluation but it's the same basic
structure and then just to wrap things
up and I can implement what a factor is
so a factor is either a bracketed
expression or it's an integer so let me
write the parser for that so a bracketed
expression I just parse a character and
then I part as an expression and call it
X and then I pars a closed bracket and
then I return the X or I can part an
integer and again if you look at the
structure of the rule up here a factor
is a bracketed expression or an integer
I've got exactly the same thing down
here here I'm parsing a bracketed
expression and here I'm parsing an
integer and this is actually our entire
parser we've got three lines up here and
we've just got kind of ten or fifteen
lines down here and this is actually a
complete
and evaluator for arithmetic expressions
and again the beauty of this approach is
the parser looks basically the same as
the grammar so let's try and see if this
works and hopefully I haven't made any
mistakes so let's load it into the
system okay that's great no errors and
we can see that we've loaded two files
in though we've loaded the parsing file
in which is about four and a half pages
of definitions we've loaded the example
program in though so now we can check
does our parser actually do what we want
so let's try out our parser with the
little example that we had at the start
two plus three times four so we're going
to parse an expression and the
expression is two plus three times four
and we press return and we hope we get
the right result and we do so remember
from school you do the multiply first
you do this three times four so you get
12 and then you add the two on at the
end and you get 14 so we've managed to
get the result 14 here and there's no
portion of the input string left so
we've got a successful result we've got
a list and we've got one result for you
we've got 14 and we've managed to
consume the whole thing or make a check
does this actually work with more
sophisticated examples so let's try
putting some brackets and let's put
brackets around the 2 plus 3 so we get 2
plus 3 times 4 so we hope then that we
do the addition first and we get 5 and
then times by 4 to get 20 yes and it
works we can try more sophisticated
examples so let's do something like 2
plus 7 times 10 plus 8 times 20 and if
I've got the brackets right yes then it
works fine we can also check what
happens if you give it something which
doesn't parse so suppose I do something
like a partisan expression so 2 plus 3
times and I forget to write the 4 at the
end what's going to happen
well the parser will still manage to
succeed because it will manage to parse
the 2 plus 3 and we'll get the 5 out but
it doesn't know what to do with this
symbol sitting on its own so you get
that back as an unconsumed part of the
input and again we can try another
example suppose I forget to close the
brackets or do something like 2 plus 3
and I forget to close the brackets then
it won't know what to do with that at
all and we'll just get the empty string
that's basically it this is the idea of
function
parsing or Combinator parsing idea is
very simple parsers are basically
functions you define a library with some
basic building blocks or primitives some
combining forms that let you put these
things together and then you can end up
writing parsers as we've seen that look
very similar to the grammars that you
write to describe languages the man goes
to town as we would say to town the man
goes sounded to me 20 years ago and I
first stumbled on this very much like
Yoda the Jedi Master for those of you
coming into this cold and direct because
you saw the word Yoder and grep over the
entire universe